what percentage of people asked said
that they were taller than Kevin Hart oh
um right what percentage of people I'm
going to go with 77% said they were
taller than me yeah I'm going to go d uh
76 to 100% but people thought that they
were taller than me let's see here D all
right 82% by the way you guys are all
but you don't know you don't
know how tall I am and I'm like 5'4 and
A2 and today I got on the boots I'm
probably like 5'5 and A2 just let you
know I'm not like I'm not like weird
small I'm very like proportion from my
size so it's not like a freakishly small
thing when you see me oh he's he's small
but he's not like small small I'm not a
double small that's a good way to
explain it